[Music]
hi everyone my name is jessie and i'm an
educator here at the peabody museum
today we're going to be making a
butterfly ring
or bracelet
so this is a very simple activity that
you can do at home
for this you'll need to have some paper
you can use construction paper
or recycled paper you'll need something
to draw with
you can use a pen or pencil crayons or
markers if you have them some tape
and some scissors so let's get started
so for this activity you can
look at butterflies in your backyard you
can watch
a video that we posted from entomology
and check out some of the butterflies
that live in the tropics
or you can look one up online or in a
book to decide what you'd like to draw
i'm gonna just use my imagination today
so the way you get started you're going
to draw a b
shape onto your paper
just like that just to get started it's
okay if it doesn't look exactly like a
butterfly
you're going to take your folded paper
and cut out along the shape
now we have the beginnings of our
sweet little butterfly so now you can
color it in
when you're happy with your drawing now
we're going to make the the ring
for our ring or our bracelet so you can
take the paper that you cut out earlier
and you're just going to cut a small
strip of paper off the top
and for this part you might need to ask
a grown-up for some help
to get it the right size to be able to
put it on your hand or your wrist
so when you have your piece of paper
you're going to fold it over
onto itself to make a little ring just
like that
you can take a piece of tape and stick
it onto the part where the ring closes
and then you're going to fold the tape
into the ring to close it so you can see
just like that this one's kind of small
i think it'll fit on my finger
so before you put it on you want to take
another piece of tape
and we're going to create a second ring
so take one edge fold it over and stick
it onto itself
and you're going to take your tape ring
and put it right onto your paper ring
now we can put our butterfly on
and it'll be ready to go there you go
great job everyone feel free to send us
pictures of the ones you make
you